Mi-na, here's what I have for you.
Take a close look at these profiles and tell me which guy is the best man for you.
I have a good-looking guy, a wealthy one, a smart one,...
...and of course other guys with various careers.
What's the most important component you look for?
Well, appearance is obviously the first thing I see,...
...so the way he looks, maybe.
Then if I have a chance to talk to him, I will observe the way he speaks...
...or the things he says, along with the vocabulary he uses.
When people talk about their lives,...
...I find that it is easy to know about them...
...and to find clues about who they are as a person.
Back to where I was, next, I will find out what he does for a living.
When it comes to careers, I don't value jobs like lawyers, doctors and professors.
I want to know if he enjoys what he does and if he is good at it.
This is what I value.
It may sound easy, but finding such a path...
...is what I consider the most important thing.
Then, I would check on his relationships...
...with his family members, siblings, friends and other people around him.
What about you Alex?
Are you more like a "love at first sight" kind of guy?
I have to admit that I am somewhat a "love at first sight" kind of guy.
I think what I really look for is how much she is willing to devote herself...
...to our family, kids and their education and careers.